jake paul and tommy fury many of you
guys already know this right by now but
their fight is off
yeah what happened tommy fury pulled out
he said he broke a rib and he had uh
some other like health issue
and
so
jake paul on december 18th my wedding
night
is going to be fighting tyron woodley
for the second time and said he's giving
him a 500 000 bonus if tyron woodley
knocks him out
now i think he's doing that because
there was rumor swirling around i think
our boy dylan danis might have started
these rumors that it was in the contract
that tyron couldn't knock out jake
so he might be trying to
dispel that rumor or he might just be
like i'm going to pay 500
500 000 some [ __ ] talk about
that [ __ ] yeah and now tyron has taken
this on less than two weeks notice
yeah
if we believe everything at face value
yeah if we believe that this wasn't the
plan the whole time oh but why would
tommy fury agree to that because he
fights him later on and it just hypes
that fight with tommy fury even more yes
dude now he takes it he takes a little
bit of a hit initially
but
it gets bigger as it goes on now there's
also a situation where tommy fury's
family i think his pops
was calling out jake for not wanting to
take the usada testing
so maybe he broke his rib
but maybe they're really like i'm not
going to [ __ ] have him fight this guy if
he's not willing to get tested and he
could potentially be on roids why didn't
i just say that though that's the best
movie he's like yeah this guy's not a
green team it looks [ __ ] bro like you
shouldn't care if a youtube guy is doing
steroids
you gotta care yeah now you should care
because the kid can box but if they're
gonna take this whole position like he
should he can't box it just from youtube
he's nothing i'm gonna go out there i'm
gonna lay him flat out and now you're
like but i won't even rule someone
testing i don't want him on performance
and drugs he's like are you scared just
fight yeah but just fight fair that's
what i'd be like yeah just fight fair if
you're going to say the kids on steroids
i'd be like ah it makes sense but
they're already saying it's not a fair
fight they're like i'm a real boxer and
you're a youtuber that's not fair
but i feel like you could spend that you
could be like yo if we're doing a real
boxing match you do drug testing are you
a real boxer then come to get tested one
hundred percent invite anyone who's on
steroids maybe he doesn't want to throw
that idea out there because then if like
people stay if those rumors start about
jake that he's on the roy's then it's
like oh well these wins have asterisks
next to him yeah and then like you it
lowers your excitement to watch his
fights he's like ah this is this
youtuber on steroids
so i'm saying why doesn't tommy fury's
can't come out with because he probably
still plans to fight him later on he
knows that's not gonna keep the value of
this fight and he could be legitimately
injured right like shitty timing it
happens like you're boxing you're
training boxing like literally there was
a video of tyson fury just a couple
weeks ago with his father like slamming
a medicine ball
you saw that yeah slam in a minute what
are you laughing at just laughing out
more exposed to a good flash just
around yeah
yeah flat though i'll give you that
thanks
what are we saying oh yeah so like tyson
fury there was a video that he just put
out recently
throw in the medicine ball his pops are
throwing a medicine ball at his stomach
and then his ribs and then he literally
yelling at his pops break my rib
break my rib yeah well yeah
yeah you know some people built
different
you know because i don't think uh tommy
had it like that it's a bummer it was
gonna be a big fight and i think like an
interesting fight and
more interesting than the tyrant fight i
have no interest in this rematch yeah i
thought the 500 000 when you said it my
first thought was that's the only way he
could try to get us to give a [ __ ]
is maybe he'll not this guy's going to
go for the knockout
yeah i don't care
now i think it's a good investment
because
in order for tyron to knock out jake he
has to take risk
and risk puts him in position to also
get knocked out
so it's almost like you're incentivizing
him to fight in a more dangerous way
yeah you're incentivizing him you go hey
here's a half a million if you get me
try to get me out you're gonna start
lunging forward i'm gonna catch you with
a counter sit your ass down it was hard
to catch you clean before now i'm going
to catch you clean because you're going
to be way
more antsy and way more risk
you know
yeah i just i also was just thinking the
pr machine behind jake seems like it's
quieter all of a sudden
since the tire and fight it doesn't seem
maybe they're going to ramp it up these
next two weeks but i i don't
hear much about i don't what do you
think it is he usually ramps it up like
two weeks before the fight oh which
would would be now yeah but yeah i don't
know i think it's a setup
it's a blistered peppers setup it's like
there's only one main event that night
oh yeah
yeah
from inside
that's possible yeah they just got to
cancel that whole fight man we got more
important things to do you know your boy
getting married